i understand that like america was
founded on
on settler colonialism and stuff like
that i'm not saying that
israel doesn't have a right to be there
because you'd have to look at every
country that was founded in a kind of
ridiculous way
and and say that they don't have right
to exist but there does seem to be
um a real issue with the territorial
expansion
the the open-air prison is insane you
can't keep people like that it's
inhumane it's you know
and there does seem to be and obviously
the the american right
except for certain parts of it are are
are insanely
pro-um netanyahu
pro-israel um and then they always give
examples of like well do you know how
bad it is for gay people in gaza which
is
unlike how it is in saudi arabia which
is a party apparently or egypt or any of
our other friends
um i'm not i don't i don't i also don't
think hamas is like a high school
theater group
i'm sure that they have there's problems
there as well
now i read in an article you're in hamas
now i'm kidding but do you
[Laughter]
uh that's that's what i mean a real but
in order to be a real journalist you
kind of do have to be in hamas
how what is your life like dude because
people go whitney webb who we've had on
the show they call her anti-semitic
do you have problems at airports do you
have problems like because you
they know of you and yeah yeah so how
how much has that impacted your daily
life and what you're able to do
well i'm banned for life from getting
into
gaza and i'm probably banned from
getting into 48s of
israel uh but i haven't tried to fly
into tel aviv i feel like i
you know i feel like i know what the
outcome of that's gonna be but i was
called an iranian agent by
israel when i tried to apply to get into
gaza they said you know
i'm a propagandist not a journalist but
i'm also an iranian spy
and i i was pretty alarmed by that i'm
used to being called a russian agent or
venezuelan agent i was like that that's
scary
you know when you're called that because
we know the
we know what they do to journalists that
don't toe their line
and i'll just give you a quick anecdote
back in 2012 when i was covering
war crimes on a daily basis that israel
was committing on breaking the set my
old show
they shelled a journalist tower that
they then leveled just a couple weeks
ago the al-sharok journalist tower
and an rt camera man's leg was blown off
and my boss wrote them a letter and he
was like why did you shell this
journalist tower knowing that there were
journalists there and they were like
a everyone is a hamas target because
there were satellites on the roof and
whatever whatever and they're like b
your network has taken a side in the
coverage
so explicit admission of war crimes as
well as basically a
threat like an ominous threat to rt and
my
show i i presume by being like you're
covering war crimes and so we can
blow you up if we want to so yes i know
i'm on the radar
we know how crazy you know the law i
don't know if anyone's seen the lobby or
if you've checked that out by al jazeera
like they
go to great lengths to spy on just
peaceful palestinian solidarity
activists to subvert
and ruin their lives um and
it's it's an extreme extreme operation
so you know you got to watch out because
uh what role do you think like
like a jeffrey epstein or someone who's
uh you know i don't know who he is
working for
no idea uh could have been france
maybe zimbabwe i don't know i don't what
do i know
right and yet some would suggest
he was engaging in like a blackmail
operation for the mossad with very
high-level people
do you give any credence to notions like
that that that
uh you know this is something that many
intelligence agencies do and
i guess the cia and the massage is very
good at it like
is that potentially why you see people
that don't really look at this
with a critical lens oh my god i mean
look at what we know the mossad just did
they took out
actual just civilian like scientists in
iran
i mean this just happened a couple
months ago actually just
did a like a breaking bad style machine
gun
operation of like automatic machine guns
that just took out this guy
and it's just like this is the kind of
[ __ ] that they're doing all the time
absolutely i think that uh you know the
cia and masada are working very closely
together doing all these co-voter
operations
the only reason we even know about that
is i think because they were very brazen
and actually wanted us to net
right responsible this is part of
the kind of psyop but yeah i think that
when it comes to things like epstein
there's a lot more that we don't know
and it what really annoys me is people
have
accepted this weird alternate reality
where they're like oh the cia just
doesn't do this stuff anymore oh yeah
they used to do that you know the dirty
wars and fun
death squads and assassinations it's
like why don't you think that they would
have just gotten
better like we're in uh surveillance
capitalism where they actually like can
it's like pre-programming they know what
we're about to do like
they they have been able to sophisticate
their operations quite a bit like why
would you just assume that they're not
doing horrific
things on a daily basis like that